emily is coming here
wrong
and she's going to to talk about some of
her research she gave up university of
texas at austin her research focuses on
sort of the nexus between energy and
water away missions in extractive
industries from working a number of
areas including July and she was kind
enough to travel several thousand miles
talk to us today about water use
associated with coal mine and natural
gas production is a very interesting
pair of study down into Texas so Emily
thank you so in part because I think
that there are a number of different
pieces of this work that I'd like to
talk about a little bit today if there's
any point at which you have questions or
just want to stop and call out something
please do i hope this can be a little
bit conversational and if there are
places where people want to focus more
than others stop me we can spend some
more time there but as Jim said I I did
a lot of work over the last few years on
electricity fuel cycles and how they
affect water consumption in particular I
think in part because in a lot of cases
the extraction site hasn't been studied
as much what we really tried to focus on
in this work was extraction in addition
to some of the power plant Stefan's I'll
explain that a little bit more in a
minute but yeah basically just going to
be comparing the natural gas and the
coal-fired electricity fuel cycles in
Texas I'll get to why Texas in a little
minute not just because I'm from UT so
what I'm going to talk about today in
part why water consumption in the fossil
fuel industry is actually interesting
and I think that this gets overlooked
probably less here because the Marcellus
is so close by and so I think probably
there's more talk about it here then
there might be somewhere else and so I'm
going to start there then talk about how
we define the boundaries for this life
cycle analysis because as anyone who's
ever tried a life cycle analysis before
probably knows very very deeply it's
hard to define where you're going to
stop in this case we got kind of lucky
and just defined our boundaries pretty
much at the state line which was helpful
but I'll get into that a little bit more
later then I'll go into a bit about what
we actually found from extraction power
plant cooling
controls etc down in Texas and explain
why I think this is interesting and what
it might mean outside of Texas so first
of all just this is a way that I think
about this a little bit just in terms of
how the energy industry uses water so
there's quantity issues and quality
issues just in terms of what you're
using you are taking some amount of
water and consuming it you are taking
some amount of water and changing its
quality perhaps and then there's also
this element of adequacy that affects
both of those so do you have adequate
quantity to do what you want to do and
not have a major impact do you have
adequate quality that kind of thing so
what I'm focusing on today is quantity
but i just wanted to start off
mentioning that that's not the only
issue here and just to point out that
the study does not address things like
quality issues inadequacy issues all
that directly so why i think this is
interesting the water and energy
relationship that we see in the united
states and really all over the world is
changing fairly rapidly for a number of
big reasons some of the macro trends we
see of course our climate change big
widespread droughts and that's something
that we felt very very deeply in Texas
over the last few years actually while I
was writing this paper I had put a
placeholder for the amount of Texas that
had experienced severe drought in 2010
expecting the answer to be somewhere
around ninety percent the real answer
was a hundred percent so drought is a
big issue down there and increasingly
across the rest of the world um and then
also just the trend in the u.s.
particularly that is a long-term trend
really of natural gas and coal being
very dominant fuels in the electricity
production sector some of the more
recent changes and some of the things
that are a little bit more localized are
things like the rise of hydraulic
fracturing so the impact of energy use
on water has changed a lot since we
started fracking wells something else
being aging power plant infrastructure
so older plants tend to be less
efficient and also get less efficient as
they age so that can have big impacts on
cooling and stuff like that and also
changing power market structures so in
Texas in particular what we have is
competitive markets which means a lot of
the time you can't rely on just saying
statewide these plants are your base
load plants that are going to run all
the time and be efficient all the time
and these plants are your peakers and we
know that we design them to be that way
what you see increasingly is that plants
are called to operate in ways that they
might not
designed to do and so that can affect
the way that they use water both on the
emissions control side and on the
cooling site actually than the data why
this is interesting to study i think is
because the water and energy
relationship is really pretty under
characterised that's changed a bit but
really when you look at a lot of the
recent work even that has been published
over the last few years you keep coming
back to this one citation from 1994 and
that's really what we know about water
and extraction in particular some of the
data on power plant water use and stuff
is a bit newer but really there's not a
lot of work done in water there's great
work done in air emissions there's great
work done in waste stuff like that
although that's developing as well but
water I think tends to be particularly
under characterized part of the reason
we didn't look at quality in this paper
is because that is so under call under
characterize that we couldn't really
even get it good data that we felt
comfortable using in a publication so to
kind of explain what I'm going to be
talking about when I say fuel cycle what
we really looked at from the electricity
perspective is three major stages during
the life of a kilowatt hour so there's
the extraction stage where you get your
in this case your choler natural gas you
move on to power generation where your
big impact on water tends to be cooling
and then on the back end you tend to
have emissions controls that's less
common in the natural gas fuel cycle but
for for completeness it could start to
be more prevalent there especially as we
get into carbon capture we go into that
a little bit more later but I think some
of the interesting things to note here
are that on the extraction side what you
really have is a bifurcation between
natural gas and coal in that with
natural gas when you use water you put
it down whole you keep it down there use
it as drilling mud you drill you use it
as frack fluid stuff like that you
produce some of it but ultimately you
are putting water into the system to get
gas out on the coal side and realizing
that this is a Texas context so I'm
talking about surface mining and surface
mining particularly in aquifers really
what you have to do is take water out of
the system so in an ideal world you'd be
using pretty much no water at all but
because you need to keep your coal face
dry you have to pump a lot of water out
of these systems before you can get at
your coal and that has some impacts on
how you use water outside of that I'm
and also on the cold side although this
is something that is a little bit less
important right
now in a lot of areas where mining is
ongoing revegetation so putting the
trees in the fields and whatever it was
that was on top of the coal mine before
you started mining back on there can
take a lot of water because
reestablishing plants and stuff like
that I'm sure you both had gardens where
you stopped watering your point for a
little while and it died same thing
happens on top of coal mines and that
turns out to be a huge water usage
actually didn't go into that here
because most of the Texas mines haven't
been shut down yet but just to note that
that's an issue in both cases for power
generation we're really talking about
cooling in terms of water use on the
extraction on the emissions side rather
for coal what I'm going to talk about
today is the sulphur controls so flue
gas scrubbers and things like that some
of the other controls that you might see
for particulates or NOx and things like
that don't really use water so they're
excluded here just to give you a sense
of what we're talking about so on the
defining the boundaries point a couple
issues to talk about here when we were
trying to figure out how to do this life
cycle analysis looking at Texas in
particular because that's where we had
good data we decided that we wanted to
look basically at the water consumption
that was occurring within the state so
from a geographic perspective defining
that state boundary was an easy step
defining what exactly felt into that
state boundary was a little harder so
this graph kind of shows a little bit of
what I'm talking about in that we
decided to include all gas and coal that
was extracted within the state that was
used within the state for power
generation so this excludes some of the
gas that gets exported for example and
it also excludes a lot of the coal that
gets imported Texas imports about
two-thirds of its cold turns out that
that coal which is coming from Wyoming
doesn't use a lot of water so it's not a
huge analytical detail to omit it that
said it's still something that we did
emit then looking a little bit more
closely at some of these boxes on the
extraction side we included dewatering
in other mine uses like that for the
coal on the gas side we look not only at
drilling mud and frack fluid but also at
the embedded water in province and
chemicals we had to make a few
assumptions on that side and we can talk
more about that offline or during this
whatever people have appetite for but
that was probably one of the more
interesting things we did because we had
to go off of economic models
is obviously if you don't really know
what those chemicals are if you don't
know whether you're using manufactured
proppant or sand it's hard to tell what
kind of water is actually embedded into
those systems but we made an attempt we
excluded transportation so train
transportation pipeline transportation
because it's really not a big water use
and the at this high level it didn't
make a big difference we did a little
bit of sensitivity and ultimately
decided to exclude it and then
downstream we included cooling and on
the emissions control side both the
direct water use for flue gas scrubbing
and the water that's embedded in
limestone and stuff like that that
you're actually using in the scrubber so
when you mind limestone to then put into
your scrubber you use some water much
the same way you use it Nicole mine
actually it's largely dewatering and
storm water removal so basically
included extraction cooling water and
emissions controls with a couple of
indirect effects of chemicals and
province and sulphur scrubbing materials
so just to give a quick overview again
what we looked at on the extraction side
was 11 specific unconventional gas
basins and then conventional gas we
didn't look at offshore but we look
basically at what you might use for a
conventional well that is not fracked
and then what you went used for an
unconventional well that is fracked in
11 separate situations on the cool side
what we looked at was the dewatering and
then also the other mine uses so to kind
of give you a sense of what the
dewatering use is if you've got this
coal mine this kind of trapezoidal shape
in order to keep it dry wherever you're
mining you need to pump a lot of water
out that tends to form what's called a
cone of depression so you take out a lot
more water than just the volume of the
mine that varies by geology etc and in
Texas this is a somewhat controversial
definition perhaps but the Texas Water
Development Board defines all of that
water as consumptive this is
controversial because when you think
about coal it's a lot like a Brita Brita
filter for water so a lot of the time
the water that you're actually pumping
out of these mines is quite clean unlike
the water that you might put down a gas
well or something like that so although
you are taking it out of the mind and
then discharging it somewhere and though
that is considered consumption it's a
very different type of consumption than
you might see on the gas side so even
though this is counted as consumed it's
still contributing to stream water flow
that kind of thing so just to call that
out a little bit it's pretty clean water
that's coming out of these minds but
that said it does draw down aquifers and
that can be a big deal in this state
like Texas where drought is so
significant that if you are ultimately
discharging that water into the Gulf
you're not going to get it back and that
can be a pretty big problem for you yeah
I'm sure we'll get to this waiting yeah
you just don't reject coal so you would
cold water that you extracted no it
doesn't make all that much sense just
because the mines are small enough in a
small enough user that it's not a huge
deal and so since they've been there for
quite a while they've kind of gotten
used to discharging and it does
contribute to stream flow there probably
is some downstream use but where that's
not specifically called out it's
considered consumption so yeah the
rejection poses a bit of a problem
because you'd be flooding your mind
again because they're shallow and every
day yeah Texas is pretty flat though but
yeah yeah I think this is this is again
why I keep mentioning Texas Texas Texas
because in a lot of the coal mines on
this side of the on the side of the
world like in the Appalachian you would
not have these same problems so the
Texas mines in particular are unusual in
their shallowness their lignite mines
and so they're basically still very
close to the time at which they were
swamps so there's a lot of water in
there you get the same thing up in North
Dakota less so in other basins on the
cooling side what's kind of interesting
is that we were comparing natural gas
combined cycle plants with pulverized
coal plants just because that's kind of
what you see on base Linda baseload
comparisons down in Texas and I think
that's fairly true in most of the United
States at least what we ended up seeing
was that you get a huge advantage on
cooling water needs in NGC sees vs.
pulverized coal plants not just because
they're a lot more efficient typically
but because they're partially air-cooled
so the combined cycle bit you've got a
gas turbine and then a steam turbine the
gas turbine parts air-cooled so you're
not using any water and then the steam
turbine part is cooled with water much
like a coal plant the entire coal plant
is being cooled with water to bring this
a little bit farther is kind of a side
note typically you see natural gas-fired
power plants combined cycles use the
least amount of water
of the water cold ones then coal plants
because they use some water to cool and
emit some of their heat to the
atmosphere and then nuclear plants use
the most because none of that heat is
going to atmosphere for obvious reasons
so you need a lot more water to cool
them so interesting side note at least
to me but we do see that effect pretty
strongly and so if we were comparing for
example I GCC's so integrated
gasification combined cycle coal plants
with ng CCS we probably would have seen
less disparity between the cooling uses
I'll get that to it get to that in a
minute but because those aren't actually
really used we decided to go off of
existing existing types of power plants
and then on the scrubber side I alluded
to this a little bit earlier but basic
oh this is an animation cool it wasn't
on my computer exciting but basically
you've got water that you're blowing
into this scrubber then you're also
injecting basically limestone powder and
pulling out the sulfur by having it
absorb on to the limestone so you end up
using water both to extract that
limestone and to directly cool the wet
scrubber it is true that there are
certain plants in Texas that use dry
scrubbers we took that into account but
by and large where you're seeing water
uses for these so in Texas what we found
was that the natural gas combined cycle
plants over their fuel cycle in these
steps that I described and including the
second-order effects of provence
chemicals limestone all of that used
about forty percent as much water per
kilowatt hour as the pulverized coal
plants that are currently operating um
this is based on plant level data we
actually did have data for each
pulverized coal plants operating in
Texas and the average for all the ng CCS
but just to call this that walk through
this waterfall a little bit this big
dark blue color is cooling water so what
you see here in both fuel cycles
actually is the cooling water accounts
for about eighty percent of the water
that you're consuming ultimately the
fuel bit which is the next darker bar in
both cases it counts for between ten and
twenty percent of the fuel cycle water
use water consumption and then on the
coals that you've got a little bit of a
mission so walking through this starting
with the PC the pulverized coal plant
water consumption it's about point
61 gallons per kilowatt-hour in Texas is
what we calculated we then calculated
what that water consumption would be if
the pulverized coal plant we're running
at the same heat right as a natural gas
combined cycle so just to kind of get
that effect out of the way um and what
you see is really the efficiency change
is huge just the fact that natural gas
plants tend to be more efficient not
only because they're newer but because
they're using the fuel twice combined
cycle thing you get a huge benefit from
actually all areas just by being a lot
more efficient you're using less fuel
you are using more of your heat to turn
into electricity so you're not having to
cool it as much all that kind of thing
so the efficiency boost is huge then
even on an efficiency parity point
natural gas combined cycle is use a bit
less water that's kind of the air
cooling point that I made earlier the
really interesting thing to us was that
on the fuel extraction side natural gas
plants on an efficiency parity basis use
a little bit more water for fuel
extraction than coal plants but not much
even when you account for the fact that
there's all this imported coal that
actually isn't using any water in Texas
so the the takeaway there is that
because of the way that lignite minds
work in Texas and if you assume that
dewatering is consumption even with the
impact of hydraulic fracturing and even
assuming that you get all of your
two-thirds of your imported coal for
free for water the gas is not using that
much more water per unit of energy that
turns into electricity and then the coal
and that was a surprise because I think
we were expecting to see that natural
gas combined cycle plants we're using a
lot less water on the cooling side and
obviously on the emissions side because
they don't have emissions controls
typically but to see that even with
fracking the water consumption for fuel
is fairly similar was a pretty big
surprise go into more detail on that in
a minute then just to finish it up the
emissions controls you get a boost on
the gas side because you don't have them
and then ultimately we get about a
quarter of a gallon per kilowatt hour
for a natural gas combined cycle plan
yeah yeah I know the quality is not was
not part of the study but yeah for the
cooling do they do require what are the
same temperature for both of these
roughly that's what's saying so Texas
plants and this is kind of interesting
because most coastal states and Texas is
a coastal state and from California and
had trouble accepting that for a little
but it is coastal a lot of coastal
states you see water for power plant
cooling it's not really true in Texas
because what you see is that refineries
take up a lot of the industrial space on
the coast and so your power plants are
further inland using strings so yes they
take about the same temperature put out
the same temperature they're both using
river water typically they're a couple
ground water cool plants but not many
yeah the confusion so why are you so do
you do a sensitivity analysis of the of
the
yeah a little bit this one we kind of
took our best guess estimate but so on
that what we found was that in both
cases for province and for chemicals it
was actually surprisingly close for each
but using some of our economic inputs
things like that did a lot of digging
through 10 k's of profit companies um
you get kind of the amount of water that
you're using on site for a drill
drilling situation plus between about
eight and thirty percent each for the
chemicals in the province that you're
using that's the higher level is
assuming and again because our boundary
was Texas the higher boundaries assuming
that everything is manufactured not mind
because you can mind some province and
that it's all mind and manufactured in
Texas so all in I think probably overall
the province and the chemicals together
at about sixty percent to the on-site
water use as the high end about twenty
percent on the low end so because the
extraction piece is small enough you
don't see a huge difference in the
assumptions that you make at this level
but when you start going into really
water used per million btu or something
like that there's a bit of a change
there the bigger effect actually is
which basin you're looking at so I'll
flip to that slide in just a minute but
what we found was that between
unconventional guests across the eleven
basins that we looked at there was a
spread of like two or three X depending
on which base and it was so there's also
that going on a little bit maybe I will
actually just start there because they
think that this might be more
interesting to talk about given that
were a little short on time um yeah I
want lots of questions though and if
people have to leave I'd love to get to
those so this is this is actually more
interesting than the other stuff anyway
let's just go here um basically this is
a chart across the 11 unconventional
basins we looked at conventional gas and
Texas lignite of how much water per I
think my unit is gallons per million
BTUs for each of these energy sources so
to walk through this little bit this red
bar is conventional natural gas so
that's just drilling fluid there's no
frack fluid associated with that this is
just the mud that you keep the bit cool
with that kind of thing um as you step
through the
the other basins and I'll point out a
couple things here in a minute you see
that on the high end which we determine
kind of the Barnett in the Haynesville
we're at the high end of water
consumption they're using kind of six
gallons per million btu where's things
like the anadarko basin in the Eagle
furder using more like two one of the
really interesting reasons for that
besides geologic setting so like the
Haynesville in particular is in a swampy
area so you might expect that the the
rock is actually absorbing a little bit
more of the water you're probably
getting a little bit less benefit out of
the unit of water you put down to
actually frack stuff like that down on
this side you tend to see more of the
basins that have a lot of oil so not
quite sure how to tease that one out and
actually here we assume that all the
water was being attributed to natural
gas or oil on a BTU basis so there is an
argument to be made that actually
extracting oil takes a lot more water
than taking natural gas out just because
of the different viscosities and because
of things like water flooding those
types of practices so that number might
actually even be smaller for the actual
unit of associated gas you get in these
very oily basins but the the key
takeaway on that I guess is just there's
a pretty big spread across all of these
different basins I'd love to get my
hands on some good data for some of the
other basins the Marcellus in particular
springs to mind there are a couple of
other very very water intensive ones
that we know are more water intensive
than the more common basins but it's not
totally clear how this is dallen per
million btu yeah yeah
yes that is the EU are weighted average
so the expected ultimate recovery
weighted average for all of the natural
gas produced in Texas onshore so none of
the big ultra deep wells offshored that
are kind of interesting to look at but
also a little harder to get data for but
that's the onshore average for the 2010
to 2060 period projected it includes
some recycling the numbers are from 2010
so there's an argument to be made that
recycling will get a little bit better
but based on current technology current
recycling status that kind of thing as
of 2010 this is the expected ultimate
recovery weighted average for natural
gas in Texas about three gallons per
million btu what that immediately shows
you is that the state is waiting much
more toward these than the conventional
gas at lease on shore which is
interesting in itself and confirmed by
projections so it was good that it
worked out that way but um the the point
that I'd like to make about the coal
this bar is gallons per million btu of
coal produced in Texas out of those
lignite basins the dark brown is the non
dewatering consumption so that's the
stuff you're using to keep dust down um
for hotelling purposes like toilets and
stuff like that which does count up some
wine consumption a lot of the time
because they use their own produced
water for it equipment cooling that kind
of thing the other ninety percent of it
is dewatering water that is not assigned
to a downstream user in few cases the
mines actually discharged with the
intent of having somebody use that water
further downstream we took that water
out so this is stuff that is basically
earmarked to go out to the Gulf from the
aquifer and again it was very surprising
to us how big that number was also again
I feel like I need to reiterate the
caveat that that water's a lot cleaner
than some of the water that you might be
experiencing in other parts of the field
chain that said it is still water that
you're removing from its setting and
making less usable in the future and so
based on state state definitions it is
considered consumptive use and so that
that large number on the coal I think
was
not expected by pretty much anyone what
we did a little bit of back of the
envelope analysis to see what you might
experience some of the sub bituminous
basins so the Wyoming coal just because
that's the other cold that Texas uses
evidence and again this is not based on
great data is that it's kind of five to
twenty percent as high as this so much
much smaller that's in part because
those those mines are both bigger and
deeper and also because they're not as
much deeply in an aquifers the lignite
mines are so in a couple of cases in
Wyoming you actually don't need to do
water the mine at all just get lucky
with these sometimes hundred foot thick
seams of coal that you don't need to do
water which is convenient for the
operators but what it does mean is that
the Texas League night is particularly
water intensive yeah
so yes and no one of the things about
lignite and you see this in North Dakota
and you see it in Texas is that most of
the lignite mines are my mouth my mouth
mines my mouth plants rather because of
exactly that problem because it's lower
energy density it has a tendency to
spontaneously combust when you transport
it and when the dust starts getting
aerosolized and so what you do is take
it directly from the mine into the power
plant to avoid those problems so you
don't want to keep it wet that's going
to make it hard to burn but you also
don't want to transport it because it
would catch on fire um the other point
in both of these cases actually which is
quite different from some of the
interior coals down in Illinois and some
of the Appalachian calls that are
through the the East Coast is that these
coals both the lignite and the sub
bituminous coal from Wyoming or fairly
low energy density which means that
processing them in any significant way
is usually not worth it they're big
surface mines you scoop up the coal it's
basically generally thick seams and you
don't have a lot of rock intermingled
with it if you did you wouldn't be
mining it because it wouldn't be worth
it so you're not using water for like
flotation separation the way that you
might out here so that that consumptive
use that's not the watering is almost
exclusively dust control so that's kind
of the fun extraction stuff um and then
just just to come back to this point a
little bit because the is dewatering
actually consumption question is a valid
one this graph is the same version as
the other one but assuming that
dewatering is not actually consumption
so what you see is that the increased
water use for gas versus coal is quite a
bit higher and again this is assuming
that a lot of your call has no water
footprint at all and assuming the eor
rated weighted average for guess so it's
still not a huge effect but it is quite
a bit bigger if you assume that the
dewatering is not actually consumption
but just to give that picture efficiency
is still the huge driver here
yeah this one right this is million btu
of gas only so we did cut out the oil
versus gas production I think to clarify
the point 0 is making it's just that you
might actually be using more water than
you would if it were only guess to get
some of that oil out but we looked at
only the ultimate recovery for gas in
calculating this part so yeah there
shouldn't be any oil numbers
intermingled in here we tried to check
for that but Barnett I think it's about
the same there's no water flooding as
such that's done it's just straight
hydraulic fracturing pretty much the
same as you would do in the Marcellus or
Barnett yeah so you're something's
either are quite good yeah but it was an
interesting output um I don't know that
I expected that much spread across the
different unconventional basins actually
and again I would love to see some
outside of Texas that were analyzed in
the same way because this is basically
based on an extensive survey of
producers over I think about 10 years
and then projected out to 2060 so hard
to get compared to a true of all of
those basins compared for example to the
Marcellus is that in all those bases
you're getting back a lot more water
when you frack and then you get the flow
back you're getting up to at least 50
sometimes eighty percent in those basins
right in Marcel's it's the opposite
you're getting twenty percent back and
more cells you're leaving a lot more
water down so it would be interesting to
to look at the different numbers it's
it's also i think really interesting to
me in that sense because you are getting
a lot more of this water back but
there's a bit less pressure to recycle
it that's not universally true and
especially in some areas like the
barnett where you literally are fracking
at dallas/fort Worth Airport everyone
can see it often you're using drinking
water to do it although I think they
made that illegal a couple years ago um
it's very visible and it's
like I said Texas has been in the in the
throes of essentially the new drought of
record for the last few years and so
when people are being told you can't
water your lawn you can't do your
laundry you can't whatever even though
there's I think typically culturally a
little bit more of a pro energy
extraction stance down there than there
might be out here seeing this very
conspicuous use of water in places where
you might not have had that use before I
think has been pretty unsettling for
people and so hearing the attitudes
about what's going on that's kind of
well you know we want the gas and we
want to be producing it here and we want
to make sure that we keep this industry
alive but at the same time like my trees
all died why can you do this and I can't
and prove to me that this is actually
important given that prices are low all
that sort of stuff it's it's a very
different conversation than you get out
here from what I can tell but it's still
a very active line the pumped water from
the coal and using it for those purposes
I assume it's good they're in pretty
different places okay so unfortunately
it's kind of that nice swath that used
to be the ocean coming in from the side
so I think before opening it up entirely
to questions just the one other point I
want to make quickly with a less pretty
chart is the carbon capture and storage
point so if you did start to put carbon
capture systems onto the back end of
existing natural gas combined cycle
plants or pulverized coal plants with
existing technologies and I recognize
that there are a lot of things that are
being done that are sort of pre
combustion technologies or better immune
systems but I mean scrubbers sticking
them on the back of plants that exists
already the amount of water that you
start using per kilowatt hour drums
really really dramatically for a couple
of reasons so one being there's a huge
parasitic load associated with carbon
capture and storage so because you're
using steam to capture your carbon for
like cleaning out your immune system and
stuff like that you're taking a wasting
that would otherwise be diverted through
a generator and producing power so you
have a direct electric parasitic load on
that side that means you're using a lot
more fuel your cooling more per per
kilowatt hour that you're putting out
stuff like that and then there's also
just the direct water use of those
carbon cap
your systems so in the cold case what
you see is that you can almost double
the amount of water that you're using
per kilowatt-hour when you start talking
about putting an ambien system onto the
back the natural gas combined cycle case
is a little bit better again because
they tend to start out more efficient
they've got this air-cooled component
that kind of thing but still you're
you're increasing your water consumption
by over half again and so just kind of
an interesting point as we talk about
trying to control carbon at the same
time as we're trying to handle our water
problems at the same time as we're
trying to handle economic issues with
electricity there are a lot of competing
things that we're trying to balance here
that actually don't all go together so
just throwing that out there is kind of
an interesting looming point if we ever
do good on that path yeah in these
plants and what happens when you have a
cashiers depends who you talk to um a
few years ago the rule of thumb was kind
of thirty percent electrical parasitic
load it's more recent tests and after
they put that system in it Mountaineer
and it suggests more like fifteen
percent but still electrical parasitic
load it's pretty big and there's not a
whole lot of actual operational data so
once you start throwing in things like
load following and stuff like that it's
somewhere between probably ten and
thirty percent similar argument at least
on the extraction site actually applies
to dry cooling as well because you've
got this parasitic load so you're using
more fuel per unit of electricity that
you're putting out you're ultimately
using less overall water because you're
using less cooling water but you're
using more water to extract and that
water is coming from different places
that might be less able to do it or more
able to do it hard to say but making
certain water choices can throw
different water consequences up and down
the fuel chain either side so it's kind
of an interesting thing to think about
particularly as we start having more
basin transfer of energy so again in
Texas most of the most of the gas that
is used down there is produced within
the state that's not really true in the
rest of the US so trading off a water
impact in Iowa for one in Pennsylvania
or something like that is
a pretty real thing so I think with that
yeah what just kind of the conclusions
more efficient plants use less water so
efficiency is really really helpful in
this kind of situation cooling is the
main driver of water consumption that
was a fairly known fact previously
people have been saying that extraction
was a pretty much negligible use I think
it's more like ten percent some people
would still call that negligible but
cooling is the big driver of water use
for the electricity fuel cycle and on
the extraction site again I think that
it's probably not fair to say that it's
a negligible amount of water that's
going into our our fuel extraction
particularly when you start thinking
about quality impacts and adequacy
impacts and the geology that you're
working in matters quite a lot so
especially since they're not here I'm
just wanted to acknowledge my co-authors
and funding and open it up for questions
thank you guys yeah i actually did throw
this into last minute so we use this
kind of cool tool that you may or may
not have seen it came out of Carnegie
Mellon the economic input-output
lifecycle analysis tool they basically
go on for all sectors of the economy
it's really sweet you should check it
out per dollar of economic impact or
economic input in all the major industry
categories across the United States what
kind of error missions water emissions
water consumption water withdrawals do
you get out so what we did to get at the
province was basically try to evaluate
what's or in this case I think this
examples for the chemicals but we did a
pretty similar thing for province and
try to think about what actually goes
into that so here we looked at basically
chemical manufacturing tried to figure
out from a couple of other studies that
have been done about how many dollars
worth of chemicals go into each well and
then throw it into the tool what we
decided for our low estimate was that we
would only use the water that was
directly being put into into that
chemical manufacturer so here like if
these are all of the water withdrawals
through the whole fuel chain going all
the way back to grain farming as you see
this is again where you start to get
layers upon layers upon layers a
conservative way of looking at how much
water's actually going into the chemical
manufacturing is just to look at the
chemical manufacturing line so that was
our low estimate on the highest emmitt
we assumed that all of this and this is
a withdrawal basis but we assumed all
water withdrawals that are associated
with chemical production were counted as
consumption with the exception of the
power generation so we assumed about 1%
of the water that was withdrawn for
power generation that was feeding these
chemical plants was actually being
consumed it's a fairly typical ratio and
then just added those all together so
low estimate just direct withdrawals for
chemical manufacturing high estimate
direct withdrawals for everything and
about 1% of the withdrawals for power
generation the prop inside is a little
bit different only because some of
that's actually in mind so we looked at
both the minds and something more like
this for the manufactured ones they're
ceramics so it was a different industry
but similar approach
yes fortunately somebody a couple of
years ago actually published a study
that try actually also used this data
set which we figured out later and tried
to get a dollars per well figure which
then we could translate into a dollars
per mbtu so some of that work we were
able to validate with this other thing
that came out in the middle of us doing
this work so that was really helpful but
yeah it's a data set that is pretty rich
and kind of hard to get at but I think
more people are starting to use it it's
interesting there's a lot more detail
actually um if you are interested this
is an open source paper and
supplementary information is all online
too and there's a lot more on how we did
this if your kid is okay yeah but is
there a large difference between the
size of the work force involved in these
two different industries or did you look
at that at all on water consumption well
just I mean I again the water
consumption of the workers would not
make a big difference but I I would
assume it's some coal miners are really
thirsty no yeah there is a pretty big
difference in total employment coal
mines do not employ that many people um
and because a lot of the gas stuff is
rapid and geologically or geographically
dispersed you do see a bit more
employment on that side we started to go
down the path of some of the societal
impacts of using more gas in Texas
versus continuing to import cold or
moving away from coal and stuff like
that that gets hairy very quickly um but
yeah ultimately guest generates probably
more labor purged per mmbtu in Texas at
least might be different in other places
yeah
a little bit I think ultimately one of
the situations there's that since they
are all using the same rivers and since
a lot of those taxes tend to work on
inter-basin transfers rather than
intercity transfers or something like
that em I'm not sure how big of a change
it would have made it would be really
interesting to look at there might
actually be some impact just because a
lot of the gas plants because they tend
to be cleaner where they are are more in
urban areas where the coal plants are a
little bit outside so like Austin for
example has a couple of gas plants very
very in the middle of the city and then
the big coal plant 45 minutes outside
same river but different water demand
areas so you don't have any of the urban
demand by the coal plant you have a lot
of the urban demand by the gas plant so
maybe we didn't look at it though yeah
and I guess I don't really know
what
spin t-spin steam after
that one I'm not an expert on I know
that there are some some people talking
about recovering water off of cooling
towers I'm not sure how effective that
is particularly at older plants so I
actually I legitimately don't know so I
won't pretend to um but that is an
interesting question a lot of these are
actually still once through though so
you just you don't have a lot of
evaporative loss anyway it's interesting
to think about though I'm not sure on
the extraction site it's a lot of the
same stuff that you see elsewhere it's
on the gas side reinjection recycling
transportation that kind of thing on the
coal side it's probably more like just
finding a user downstream that is
willing to put their hand up and say yes
that is my water right and its
associated here and therefore I'm
freeing up my other water right so Texas
is a little bit strange in that it has
different sets of water right laws um so
traditionally the the rule has been
stated as biggest pump wins if it's on
your property and you can pump it it's
your water and that is your water right
you're not restricted because of
droughts and because of urbanization and
stuff like that in certain areas they
started to get a little bit more
prescriptive about who owns right
assigning senior rights junior it's all
that sort of thing so it kind of depends
where you are um but yet in the coal in
the cold case probably just identifying
somebody who's willing to speak up for
that water and claim it instead of their
other right would be one option yeah
Oh
no and the big reason for that is that
we just couldn't get the data on the gas
side the argument on the coal site is
that because it's mandated that you meet
certain quality standards you have a
pretty good idea of what's in the water
I would question that without actually
being able to go take samples just based
on the history of coal industries I
think these guys are probably probably
pretty close to there they're regulated
limits just based on some of the other
stuff that I know about those minds but
yeah on the gas side we started out
really hoping that we could do a lot of
quality analysis and the data just
aren't there so that would be great and
I hope that over the next few years
especially some of these more
underdeveloped basins start to have more
wells associated with them that we
actually will be able to get more
information because Texas now also has
disclosure rules about what you're
actually putting down hole that kind of
thing so between that and a lot of
research that's going on in the state
because it's a it's a fairly big piece
of the economy down there the gas side
anyway I hope that we will have enough
data to do that soon have you been able
to do that out here yeah we need to keep
trying because I think it would be
interesting yeah
w that
I
I phrased that poorly so like this chart
applies to the stuff you're exporting to
I guess what I what I should have said
and how I should have said that is that
we only looked at the gas that was being
used in the power sector so we assumed
that the gas used in the power sector
has the same profiles all the guess it's
being produced but we did have a little
bit of a challenge initially deciding
you know which gas really is being used
in the power sector and if you started
to add on a whole bunch of new gas
demand because you started switching
from coal to gas or something like that
which guests would you put on first
would you assign only the conventional
guess its shape to produce would you
assign the expensive guess that nobody
maybe there's not demand for unless you
start adding your own internal demand so
the marginal piece of gas that you would
actually burn in Texas it's not clear
whether that's one of the more water
intensive or one of the less water
intensive pieces of guest so we
ultimately went with the average but
that was a little bit of a speech
artifact from a long long debate that
ultimately resulted in us just taking an
average but yeah like you can make the
argument that in the absence of external
markets and if everything collapsed and
you wanted to keep running power plants
in Texas you just use the easiest gas to
get you can also make the argument that
you have all these contracts outside so
you will use the hardest gas in state so
but cost and water use don't always go
together either so going down a rabbit
hole here a little bit but we can talk
about it more later if you want
yeah water you store I bought because
they're anywhere in the same city turns
to being slow to the reception areas
where the drawing down water for ipod
fracture exactly yes it's partially not
in every case but there are enough shale
basins that and texas is agricultural
enough still that yes a lot of its ranch
land admittedly so it's not like the
great fields of corn that you might have
elsewhere but yeah I mean the lot of the
Texas cattle started getting herded
basically north because there wasn't
enough water to keep them alive in the
last couple years and so yeah it
definitely is a real trade-off and one
of my colleagues actually has done a
little bit of work trying to see how you
could do transfers between agriculture
and energy production by like having the
gas producers pay for more efficient
watering systems and stuff like that so
they are coincident for sure
they're often the same people that's not
universally true but just in terms of
who actually has huge bits of land and
who actually owns all the rights to that
land because it's been in their family
for a long time or whatever so they've
got the mineral rights and the surface
rights the ranches are where you're
drilling so yes it's a trade up and I
think it's it's an interesting economic
thing to watch too because depending on
gas prices versus beef prices for
example you might trade off which one
you're devoting more water to in a given
year I'm speaking a bit off the cuff I
actually haven't looked into that
specifically but I suspect that you
probably would see that effect a little
bit but yeah it's it's interesting
because their shale everywhere um so
development is moving toward the south
west because that's where the liquids
are yep exact prices are low oil prices
are so high so and that's a Nigeria to
him interesting I don't know how many of
you have seen the NASA pictures Jim and
I were talking about it a little bit
earlier but just looking down and being
able to see all the flares in the back
end and then being able to see the ego
ferd as well I still have some questions
about whether that's electrical lighter
flares or both but the bakken's players
yeah
it's a great place so I know Texas most
of Texas is like a very strange
deregulated energy
it's it's what California did right
before the major power crisis one of the
classes I took at UT actually the
professor basically walked in and is
like we didn't fix any of the problems
that they had but n runs out of business
now so maybe we'll be okay that aside
yes um it is a pretty interesting thing
because you have the gas plants and the
coal plants competing really really
truly directly here I mean energy
utilities in Texas have gotten to the
point where they'll like offered to send
you flowers on your birthday is one of
the advantages that you have for
choosing I mean it's it's pretty funny
actually sometimes or like free power
during the Superbowl stuff like that
like it's a little gimmicky almost at
this point I think UT itself actually
has branded electricity now so you pay a
little bit of a premium and that goes to
the University anyway um it's an it's a
wild market down there a bit and that
does have some impacts on how these
plants actually operate that I don't
think that the data sets that we use
necessarily incorporated most of our
plant level data was kind of 2008 to
2010 which is before most of the
competitive completely deregulated modal
market started to come online now what
you would probably see is that because
more coal plants and even more of the
natural gas-based load plants themselves
are being asked to load follow more than
they were before because it's no longer
as simple as just or cot saying that's
the grid in Texas just saying you know
you go you go you go but it's actually
competitive at the time of running um
you probably see efficiency drops for
some of the plants and that probably
means that they're using a little bit
more of their water
it's not my oming so yeah the the big
federal swaths of land you don't have to
the same extent as you do in a lot of
the West proper um I think most of it's
privately owned there are some really
really big parks but most of the places
where you actually have production I
think are privately owned by Kieran
depends on which public land you're
talking about so like a perfect example
being both UT in Texas A&M our
land-grant universities one of the big
issue and this is like a strange version
into Texas politics but one of the big
issues is that the land that the
University of Texas System was given is
in the Permian Basin so there's a lot of
oil there that goes directly to the
University that's all considered public
the land that am got is a lot more
agricultural less oil revenue from it so
the money balance to the two schools
comes out differently so like in that
sense there is public land and this has
an effect on how the state works but I
don't know how significant that is
overall